let me ask first of all about Mercedes
getting into the game what in what seems
like a little bit of a late fashion here
I mean GM has the bolt BMW has the i3
obviously Tesla's built around this
model but why so long well I think a lot
of the German automakers you know we're
very committed to diesel that they've
been a you know championing for a
hundred years and even five or ten years
ago when when Tesla was was first
getting going it still didn't look like
it was economical I mean the company
still loses money and it's expensive to
do these big batteries that make a car
drive as well as we expect from a
Mercedes or a BMW or for that matter a
Tesla
since then the costs have come down and
the cost of doing diesel has gotten
higher with the you know the since the
diesel gate says Volkswagen scandal
emissions-cheating scandal it's gotten a
lot tougher to sell diesel cars in this
market and other places around the world
so they're making the big push into
electric as Matt pointed out other
companies besides Tesla are doing
electric cars how have they done if
you're an electric car buyer are you
interest are people interested in those
other ones or are they just saying I'm
going to buy an electric car why not
just get a Tesla well Tesla is
absolutely the market leader you know
we're seeing most of this action in
California which requires a certain
amount of electric vehicles to be sold
to meet their their zero emission
vehicle standards so that mostly means
electric cars could be a few fuel cells
you know Tesla's had great success and
they have a better chance of making
money because their prices are high
because they're a luxury car maker and
so that's where Mercedes or BMW might
have a fighting chance to they have more
stores than Tesla and they can also
command a high price it's so much harder
for Chevy or Nissan with mainstream
brands to make up for all that cost of
the development and the cost of the
batteries and there is I mean we should
point out Jamie that there are most
every brand has an all-electric model
you know Ford has a plug-in all-electric
model Nissan obviously has a plug-in
all-electric model but those were icy II
originally internal combustion cars
fitted with batteries something like the
Chevy bull
or the the BMW i3 or these cars from
Mercedes army built I'm assuming from
the ground up to be electric cars right
and that cost billions or at least a
billion dollars to design and start a
new car from start to finish yeah
especially with the new powertrain as a
new program you're probably talking
billions to get anything real going the
the Nissan was a new car from the ground
up the leaf was pretty a pretty unique
project but yeah it's and vedettes again
we're the established players so we may
be seeing a turning point in electric
right where it's not just a handful of
experiments or you know Tesla which is
trying to start a revolution but these
big companies that are well-established
and already have billions of dollars and
make billions of dollars on their
traditional business can funnel that
into the new technology to try to reduce
pollution and be ready for whatever
future the regulators will allow so
since Mercedes has been to hold out here
in terms of coming up with an electric
vehicle
what is its strategy in getting into
this market is it going to make its own
version of the electric vehicle that's
incrementally better than what it has
and it's a normal car lineup or is it
going to try to reinvent this category
of it well I mean we're going to see
this is still you know people familiar
and products that are still being
developed and are and are on their way
to coming out but I mean what we do know
is that it looks like they're coming at
it with a full lineup right they're
talking already about two cars two SUVs
you know a work truck a heavy truck you
know for commercials for businesses you
know that's like Tesla's five-year plan
right and they're already they're going
from zero to 100 I guess you know go and
fold full-bore so they're coming at it
hard they've got the resources and
they're putting them to work